fuck is this shit
who the fuck would send me this shit
I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark
I love my eyes I miss my baby
that's what what
welcome to my hilarious 'ti review of
Dragonball Evolution or as I like to
call it disgusting bile extract I often
get a question what is your all-time
favorite movie well I don't have one I
just can't pick it's too hard but I have
had the exact same least favorite movie
of all time ever since I saw Dragonball
Evolution I hate everything about this
movie now I have reviewed this before
you guys may know this some of you may
not they're older videos I don't like
the way they look there was more to say
let's do it why do I hate Dragonball
Evolution well let's talk about
everything about this movie that I hate
this movie opens with an incredibly lazy
narration it's almost like they filmed
the whole movie and went oh shit
this doesn't make any sense we better
make some stupid CGI narration in the
beginning to sum everything up in the
show King Piccolo fought a very young
Goku Goku defeated him in King Piccolo
gave birth to piccolo as we came to know
him throughout the show Goku and piccolo
were enemies for a while they had
battles at various tournaments but
eventually they became friends and
allies in this movie piccolo has been
reduced to simply a power-hungry war guy
who wants to destroy everything and
hates everyone
for no reason in the show there was
motivation there was a reason for
piccolo thinking that way he was also a
complex character having a good side and
a bad side this movie doesn't give a
shit about any of that it just wants
piccolo to be the big evil guy who has
absolutely nothing interesting about him
the movie is directed by James Wong and
I've liked some of his work before I
enjoyed the x-files a lot he wrote some
of the best episodes and I even enjoyed
some of the final destination movies
that he directed but here I don't know
what happened it's almost like this
movie was just canned at the last minute
because it's like 80 something minutes
long with credits I mean that's pathetic
a movie like this should have been at
least 2 hours and good but at the same
time I'm also grateful that it's
mercifully short this opening fight
scene between Goku and his grandpa is so
laughable there's nothing about it that
looks real the entire thing looks as if
it was shot on a green screen and none
of it looks as if it's actually
happening it is the fakest looking shit
I've seen in an action movie since like
ultraviolet have you seen
if you have I apologize my god like Goku
slapping a CGI fly into his grandpa's
mouth what is the purpose of any of this
instantaneously in just one fight scene
I know I am in for a complete shit so
let's talk about the character of Goku I
use bunny ears because it's definitely
not Goku portrayed by Justin Chatwin
let's get this out of the way I don't
have anything against this after he's
talented I have no problem with him as
an actor or as a person seems like a
cool guy but my god was he saddled with
the dumbest fucking horrible
interpretation of one of the coolest
manga characters to be ever drawn or
animated this Goku is actually a whiny
high schooler who's more obsessed with
beating up the bullies that are picking
on him and getting the girl that he has
a crush on than anything watching these
early scenes with him complaining to his
grandpa about wanting to get the girl at
school and wanting to beat up those
bullies and this amazing delivery right
here they pushed me so far that I want
to explode so I could tear them apart
with one hand it makes me truly wish
that I had seven dragonballs of my own
so that I could wish this movie out of
existence in the show
Goku did want to become stronger but
that's because he had an obsession with
fighting not with wanting to harm others
or beat people up he was a Saiyan and so
he felt that need for battle but he was
also sort of a pacifist he didn't
necessarily want to fight someone he
only did it to protect those he loved
this movie has a teen angsty Goku who
gets pissed off a lot and makes a poop
face quite often something else I
noticed after re watching this movie
because yes I rewatched it and my god it
was torturous Justin Chatwin often
ceases to act after he gets his lines
out teach me how to be normal normal is
also overrated
did you notice how his face just went
completely emotionless after he got his
line out now if your Dragon Ball fans
like myself you know that in the show
the Dragon Balls are very exciting
objects in this movie when Goku is
grandpa gives him the four star ball he
just looks at it like it's nothing he's
like that's cool that's it's nice I'll
keep it
safe always thanks grandpa there's no
aah or a wonder or excitement or sense
of adventure he's just this angsty
teenager who's like oh thanks for the
stupid ball grandpa thanks a lot I
appreciate it hey can you tell me about
this girl thing I don't know can you
give me some condoms I need some condoms
okay grandpa I really want to fuck
chichi is that okay I just need some
condoms fuck this dumb dragon ball sorry
I just want to go fuck is that alright
with you let's talk about James Marsters
as piccolo he is probably the one thing
in this movie that sometimes receives
praise I call this the Ewan McGregor
syndrome what's the one thing about the
prequels that most people are like yeah
that's fine you and McGregor
because he was the one thing that was
just fine you know he was okay everyone
else was very dry and just black at
least you and McGregor as obi-wan Kenobi
you can watch the prequels and be like
he's doing a good job he seems like a
good obi-wan Kenobi because everything
else surrounding you and McGregor is
like yeah that's James Marsters in this
movie he's the one person who's like
okay that's all right I guess because
everything else is such shit
so during class goku has a stupid
fucking dumb daydream about chichi
eating a strawberry because yeah goku is
just a hormone fueled teenager actually
in the show goku had no idea what a girl
was in the show when he ran into Bulma
for the first time he had never seen a
woman in his life he asked boma where
her tail was because he just thought
everyone was like him well you look
human enough but you're different you're
thin and scrawny I'm a girl silly that's
why a girl oh so that's what you are
oh my gosh are you saying you've never
seen a girl before nope
besides my grandpa you're the only human
being that I've ever seen in the show
chichi even tricks Goku into getting
married
that's how innocent and naive of a
character he was in this fucking shit he
just looks at chichi and goes oh man I
really want to bone her and then he
tells the teacher the dynamics were a
race of people 2,000 years ago that
tried to destroy the entire earth
they're not a peace-loving people that
just enjoys raising their families and
being pacifists like they were in the
show this movie takes everyone in the
show that hated violence and wanted to
stay away from violence and turns them
into power-hungry bullies it's such an
American viewpoint of such a great
Japanese manga it makes me sick let me
get some awkward romantic babble between
Goku and chichi where he just blurts out
that chichi is not a normal name yeah
because Goku is the king of normal names
with each passing scene it becomes
incredibly obvious why akira toriyama
the original creator was so horrified by
this movie that he wanted to resurrect
the films and the show with battle of
gods and resurrection f as well as the
upcoming Dragon Ball super true story
the guy was fuckin horrified by this
movie just like all of us
so chichi invites Goku to her party and
right here we are literally 14 minutes
into this movie and I can't fucking take
it anymore 14 minutes and I cannot take
it I've got to fucking do something
something more fun than watching this
movie I got to do something sorry guys
d9 miss b6 miss where the fuck were I oh
yeah I'm still 14 minutes into this
fucking shit
alright so Goku goes to chi Chi's party
whooping he fucking do he gets attacked
by some bullies why are these bullies
kung fu masters why did it make
Dragonball Evolution a cliched awkward
teen romance for the CW network why is
this such an obvious stunt double
why did they hire an actor to play the
biggest badass of all time who doesn't
want to do his own stunts I mean did
they hire Justin Chatwin because of his
role in War of the Worlds when he had
Dragon Ball toys on his shelf is that
the only reason it has to be so
apparently piccolo can use the force he
crushes grandpa's house now please
observe this oscar-worthy acting as
Goku's grandpa dies
honestly the best acting in this movie
is Justin Chatwin's forehead vein and of
course before Goku's grandpa dies he
gives him this quick speech to let us
know that there is a story he has to
find all the dragonballs before the
eclipse occurs what is that fucking have
to do with anything now we meet this
movie's version of Bulma played by Emmy
Rossum and that's totally her voice
she's not 80-yard at all if I wasn't
Hickel oh whatever that is I wouldn't
tell you and if I did kill your
grandfather I would have shocked you by
now somebody stole my promethium orb and
I'm here to get it back and in this
movie guess what they refer to the
dragon radar as Dragonball energy DBE
catchy name DB II that's funny you're so
clever Pat yourselves on the back
writers you made a good one let's talk
about the fact that this movie does in
small ways try to pay homage to who Goku
as a character really is in the manga
and the show in the next scene they have
him eating a gigantic leg of meat and in
the show it's like this thing that Goku
is always very hungry he can eat a ton
of food and it's very funny it's very
cute
that's Goku in the show but in this
movie it makes no sense because the
character they're portraying is this
angsty teenager who's on a street in the
middle of the night with Bulma trying to
find Master Roshi and he's just eating a
leg of meat I know as a fan of Dragon
Ball that they're trying to tribute Goku
who is always hungry and loves to eat a
lot of food but it doesn't make sense
for this movie because the character
they're portraying is this annoying
hormone fueled teenager so why in the
hell would he just be eating a giant leg
of meat in the middle of the road the
movie is trying to honor certain things
about his character like giving him a
hoodie that's orange and blue but
doesn't work with a dumbass character
they've already created so it just comes
off stupid and tired so now we get
introduced to chow yun-fat as Master
Roshi this is potentially a great idea
this is a very good actor in a very good
stuntman in films like Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon or some of John woos
earlier films if I were to read chow
yun-fat cast as Master Roshi I'd be like
that's great good job and they tried to
give him a few fun elements like how
he's still kind of a
reverting everything and this would all
be okay if it didn't look like such
utter shit look at this fight scene it
looks like Mortal Kombat annihilation
took a shit and the shit that Mortal
Kombat annihilation took was the fight
scene and Dragonball Evolution we're
watching right now later on in this
scene we have Master Roshi laughing and
this close-up of him stopping laughing
observe hahahahaha my grandfather's dead
they're trying to tribute moments in
Dragonball like this I get it I get what
they're doing but some things only work
in anime and do not translate to film
speed racer' by the Wachowski z' proves
that wholeheartedly this scene also
contains the worst line delivery in the
movie by far and some of the worst
acting I've ever seen and I'm not
exaggerating
he was murdered I will avenge him but
before he he died he asked me to find
you and to tell you that piccolo has
returned
isn't this so much better yeah so Bulma
and Hiroshi and Goku team up to go
somewhere because they all have to find
the dragonballs before the eclipse and
blah blah fucking shit who cares bro she
makes Goku carry this giant sack which
was a tribute to Dragon Ball where oh
she made Goku and krillen there is a
character named Crillon right and Dragon
Ball I believe he's go who's best friend
you know what I don't care these not in
this movie because it's one character
that wasn't completely destroyed by this
movie as well as Tien thank goodness for
that
but anyway they attempted again to pay
homage to this moment in Dragon Ball and
that's all Dragonball Evolution has to
offer brief little moments that attempts
to pay homage to the manga but the film
that they are making is so stupidly
modern with this angsty teenager
jennifer Love Hewitt
fucking shit type drama that it doesn't
work whenever they try to tribute the
actual manga so they run into chichi at
the tournament and guess what she's a
fighter - so Goku has even more of a
hard-on for now and what is with all
this airbending shit ro she's trying to
teach Goku about the Kamehameha wave and
everything and he makes it seem like
it's airbending this isn't avatar guys
Dragonball is not about airbending for
fuck's sake so let's talk about the next
character this movie destroyed and that
is Yamcha what a cool fun character in
the original show I loved Yamcha he was
so much fun and apparently James Wong
took one look at this actor and just
said Yamcha you look like him you seem
like it could be a douche your Yamcha
wonderful and his lines are definitely
not 80-yard either that CV thing is
right if all you're looking for is right
here
when our heroes fall down a giant hole
they make a campfire for roshi to tell
stories with the fire that's right Roshi
makes images appear in the fire because
he's a magical wizard again Yamcha why
is he such a fucking bro well everything
happens for a reason bro got that one
from daytime TV I'm expecting this guy
to just be like fuck you guys I'm about
to go play some football with my friends
have some beer and wings and yell really
loud now the movie reminds us that there
is in fact an antagonist piccolo creates
monsters by extracting his blood and
these monsters form and attack everyone
on this lava thing and they slice him up
and create a bridge with them so that
Goku can cross this bridge to get the
Dragonball you know there are parts of
this movie that I actually hate so much
and this is one of them so I'm just
going to move on now
so Goku gets the Dragon Ball and it
gives him a vision of the future that's
right Goku is now a clairvoyant psychic
I can't I can't do this guy's I can't
fucking do this I I can't
yes could I please have a McChicken with
extra lettuce and onions added to it
yeah I'll take a US four piece chicken
nugget yep
thank you next we're gonna see Moreau
she explains everything to us again
because we need a scene after every
action scene for somebody to go okay
guys there's still a plot here's the
plot just want to remind you there's
still a plot there is a plot exposition
exposition plot exposition next we get
character building moments I guess row
she meets up with an old friend with a
white painted beard Bulma and Yamcha
walk around and discuss things
chichi and Goku walk around and discuss
things this is the movies attempt to
give us character development and it's a
bullshit fest of fuckery but that's okay
because next we get more airbending
ships Roshi is trying to teach Goku
about the Kamehameha wave which
apparently he's not able to master yet
because Goku is only 18 years old
he was like 12 in Dragonball when he did
it for the first time and he surprised
everyone around him bullshit so someone
pretending to be chichi starts this
awkward looking fight where tuti she's
fight one another and Goku's dumbass
knocks out the real chichi because
apparently in this movie goku is not
able to sense people in the show goku
could sense anyone's inner power he
would be able to sense who the real
chichi was oh wait a second he can sense
people because this scene is here how do
you know hmm i can always sense my
grandfather
oh so i guess he can't sense people so
why didn't he sense which chichi was
real in this moment because this script
is fucking dumb that's fucking why goku
then gets half killed slash knocked out
and he has this crazy vision that made
me laugh so fucking hard grandpa I'm so
happy to see you but it's okay not to
worry
Roshi resurrects Goku with his
Kamehameha wave
the Kamehameha wave is one of the most
famous attacks in anime history it's an
attack not a resuscitating attack it's a
deadly attack this is honestly as bad as
if somebody made a Star Wars movie where
lightsabers no longer cut through things
if you like impaled somebody with a
lightsaber it brought them back to life
so my wife was nice enough to rewatch
this movie with me she was like look we
said we'd go through pain together and
we're gonna re-watch Dragonball
Evolution together she's a big Dragon
Ball fan too and in this scene with
piccolo she just goes piccolo looks like
he belongs in a Joel Schumacher Batman
film and I laughed my ass off she is so
right he looks like fucking Bane or
anything in Batman and Robin it's
atrocious so now the whole big finale
starts in CGI green-screen yeah so about
Goku's costume reveal this fuck my life
fuck it so Goku becomes as aru the big
ape thank goodness they in some way
maintained that storyline at least but
my god does it look like such shit just
look at this fucking shit fuck me in the
ass
so Roshi dies because you know freaking
obi-wan Kenobi died in Star Wars and
qui-gon died in Phantom Menace so they
have to have the old guy who teaches
things die and Goku somehow convinces
himself to revert back to his normal
form because he just has to be really
strong and overcome piccolo in this
fight none of this makes any fucking
sense at this point I just want the
movie to end so the quicker that it ends
the better
so here Goku and piccolo finally have a
fight and you guessed it it looks like
garbage but what really occurs in this
fight
well Goku takes one to three punches
falls down and suddenly becomes perfect
that's right one tiny little skirmish
lets him know what he has to do and he
stands up and he's like I am
Xaro I am Goku to be one with myself I
have to be to flex the forehead vein
poop face seriously after that little
tiny fight he instantly becomes perfect
and masters the Kamehameha wave and
blast piccolo until piccolo dies so
isn't that just shit my god that shit
but listen to this for a second what
happened earlier when ro she blasted
Goku with a Kamehameha wave well it
resurrected him for some reason the
kamehameha at the end of the movie kills
like it's supposed to so what's the
difference between the resurrection
Kamehameha wave and kill people
kamehameha wave so goku gets the Dragon
Balls and wishes Roshi back to life and
he comes back to life and yes and of
course it ends with some more romantic
bullshit between Goku and chichi and
more 300 style slow-mo fast moving
slow-mo fast moving action the end but
you know what the funniest part of this
movie is there's a mid-credits scene
where piccolo is still alive being cared
for by someone and it sets up a sequel
okay this is the last reviewer
Dragonball Evolution I'm ever going to
make this is my final farewell to this
movie I have said everything there is to
be said but wait there is still
something that I must do
yes I feel it growing within me
the desire to destroy
here is what remains of the husk of a
human being my husband once was after
Dragonball Evolution this is all that
remains a withered shallow corpse I wish
for seven dragonballs that could make
that movie disappear
you don't understand well we've now hit
level stage three year old really hate
that moving I am ste in my love no you
don't I do too
you don't understand it's so bad I grew
up with Dragonball Z just like you did
you know what's really funny though as I
looked at Norma the North versus this
and I think actually Dragonball
Evolution has a better rating the norm
of the North does I wonder what
redeeming qualities gave it 14 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes I feel violated I
feel disgusted I just I it's it's like
in those like demon movies where like
someone finds out an object in their
house is like possessed and like get out
of the house like that's how I feel
about Dragonball Evolution like it's
like you have it's like it's in my house
and it's like making my house gross